what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back to watch two
episodes of the bad batch 13 and 14.
joined by one chin Michael over here yes
MJ Tesla our Star Wars nerd who's lost
like what you've lost like 10 pounds 15
15 pounds that's what I'm talking about
man yeah seeing yourself on the real
rejects that'll realize
this episode is brought to you by search
elite well ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do leave a like please go ahead
leave a like Mandalorian next episode
will be out in a few hours I'm probably
editing it right now be sure to
subscribe click the notification Bell
for a reaction to the finale don't know
how I'm gonna be able to work that out
if we don't have early access to the
finale and then Mandalorian also comes
out that day and uh subscribers said
that in full length reaction with your
own copy available for super sexy
Rejects at our page restaurant page
thank you to all showing your support
and join us we're going to watch both
just back to back join us on this
journey let's see what's going on
[Music]
foreign
wasn't that your nickname in Middle
School Greg I think so are we gonna sit
here all day or can we get to business
let's see it
is
not until I know it's not one of your
two-bit knockoffs
smart thinking spoken like a person
who's bought a knockoff
can hurt the Fine Art of negotiation
do we have a deal
it's not blue
it's like the first wine bottle I think
I've seen in Star Wars yeah Naboo 13 ABY
poison is not typically my drink
aggressive
oh
she's not a pirate she's a liberator of
ancient wonders
want to kill me you'll have to do better
than that
the thing from Attack of the Clones
oh
so but it's not only taking the artifact
now you should have brought more muscle
than that fee she did
well look at him Rising
[Applause]
cool act yeah all right fee shot first
shoes
nice yes
whatever right out of Coco yes I am
playing against myself it is the only
time this game is a challenge
[Laughter]
hurry guys did they actually get
treasure did they do it
wow
first time for everything Omega spends
all her time with you three she needs
friends
and share her genetic profile we never
had such a thing I do not see the issue
okay my parents spanked me as a child
let's hear it
um
Sid
she better be dying I've known Sid a
long time she's a useful Ally but not
someone you want to cross do you have a
plan you're looking at it
running away you all are coming with me
oh my God these coordinates brown eyes
SIDS the villain haunting them through
the Galaxy
Sid's actually an Inquisitor I just
haven't revealed it yet
it's pretty
I wonder if Luke's just looks edible it
does look a little edible
look at those
cute little clay houses it's like
something from Moana I've been staring
at the edge of the Galaxy
that's the r Kim it's where the artifact
will be stored it holds Treasures from
all over the Galaxy wait so you actually
do good things treasure can mean many
things most of the villagers on Pabu are
refugees many of the items I recover are
remnants of their cultures and that's
worth preserving what is going on a
liberator of ancient wonders
miss me ship you got some competition
would you bring this time
oh her and Omega are gonna be friends
ship Liana meet Omega Hunter wrecker and
Tech welcome
this is like Moana
he's brought any friends here with Neva
not even Sid
nope
why not Sid she must really like you
it's an interesting development then
it's settled you'll join us for dinner
there's no saying no to Shep's famous
feasts lots of food drink and general
merry making ships pie huh it'll be
great
lead the way ship I'll catch up
I like that he's a little Stout and not
like a mean cartoonish way because I'm a
fat ass this is someplace safe
oh man Tech is gonna settle down oh
what's going on
[Laughter]
something awful is going to happen here
this planet's way too nice not too
shabby is it
Chevy
oh
[Music]
Momo
they're called Munoz
I wasn't far off
they've lived here since before Pabu was
inhabited
[Music]
Dave filoni Avatar yeah it makes sense
Pabu has been a safe haven for those
forced to flee their homes during the
war you're not worried the Empire will
show up but if they do we'll manage well
[__] them up
[Music]
father and ask for a better place to
raise a child you know suggesting we all
stay on Pabu permanently
I don't know this place looks awful
I still like it here
a little stability might do you all some
good
nah it's going to get everyone killed Oh
sushi I love this place I wanna have my
honeymoon here
what is going on with those two you have
your own boat uh-huh you want to take it
out and watch the sunset really no that
sounds like a great idea doesn't it can
I go have fun have fun
that's an order
Soldier
good soldiers follow orders
what's with you
I'm full
I am never full
time to commemorate such a momentous
occasion
hope you say group for dessert I love
this place
how do you like
pay your dues to keep this lifestyle oh
it's a communist civilization
or it's a cult get a lot of cult Vibes
what you don't see is that meat that
they were eating were the moncals
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the happiest Omega has ever
looked I think it's also nice that it's
an island water planet and coming from
kamino this really is
surrounded by the ocean it didn't feel
like this place
yeah where's all the crashing waves and
thunderstorms you and your friends can
because it's almost time to see for
yourself
like them together yeah right I'm not
seeing anything just wait it'll be worth
it wow
what in the Disney movie is this
that is beautiful
what's wrong that rumbling
animal scurrying
Records full records it's just this
gastrointestinal problems
we need to
we're never prepared to have conflict in
our lives it's no big deal happens all
the time are you sure
yeah but let's head in
[Music]
uh
turns out it's a volcano everyone all
right
I don't think it's over
how did you know
just like living in LA
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah just like Camino I believe this
island is at risk for a significant sea
search we haven't had a sea surgeon more
than three decades the early warning
system would have activated I don't like
the sound of that that the early warning
system
[Music]
man them just arriving no I know
think about awful luck Leon and Omega
they're on the water I'll grab our ship
and get them you four move everyone in
town to Higher Ground
we gotta get the higher grounds
[Music]
use the force Omega
what a terrifying concept this is what
happens in real life during an
earthquake
it pulls the water back Leanna wake up
wake up
we have to keep moving
no like really right now
why are they having a sea search right
now because the earthquake it pulls back
and then it pushes the phone I have a
wide now today because the bad batch
arrived and the writer said no choice
but to rush it unless there's something
bigger at play here we must use
additional means to get them over the
wall we can deploy the rescue ladder
they line the top of each wall
it's like Helm's Deep yeah
Batman
nice get attack get it you take those
ladders I'll handle these
is like Helm's Deep
exactly what it is
I'll take the stairs
yes the rickety wood that hasn't been
used in 30 years yeah that's reliable
sound
this is the last one hey can I help you
oh no
[Laughter]
it's happening
leave her behind Omega she's slowing you
down she is important lesson about
friendship she finally finds a friend
her age and then we drown her
lever
don't stop running oh I've got you Mr
Frodo
whoa
it's pretty scary actually oh man it's
an awful way to go over here
throw the old man up there
just like Gimli
oh my God
oh no he's not gonna make it
for a ship
I don't know
what I meant more if he died
just saying Circle it's all right it can
still kill the girl push her long live
the king
no oh man it's a good thing to have
upper pep property was destroyed but my
people are resilient we'll band together
and rebuild we could stay and help out
with things I had the same idea if you
don't mind us sticking around for a
while
now be most welcome you guys made this
happen yeah literally we had 30 years
with no earthquakes you were cursed
[Music]
that is
On To The Next Episode immediately
immediately no time no time to ruminate
I'm sure this episode heavily ties into
the next I had so much to say about that
episode Michael please we gotta go three
two one and
[Music]
okay I like that title I feel like that
means something across her Tipping Point
killing set
I don't like the tone of this I love the
tone it feels a little too light-hearted
for me
okay all right this is gonna be good
you know I'm bad batches like these are
cinematic [__] get ready
oh
[Music]
I've done clone inmates clone mates
you're the prisoners for transport
we have a schedule why is every Imperial
such a douchebag
I'm curious why they're keeping any
clones alive that are prisoners maybe to
interrogate them I guess
whoa
Cloud Rebellion yes we're under attack
sir get us out of here jump to hide in
the space do it open fire and notify
come on
[Music]
yeah oh you're right
I gotta break those prisoners out we
need to board and recover those
prisoners before reinforcements show up
welcome back Echo
holy God
[Music]
oh smart
I love these early Stormtroopers
set to stun
nicely done nicely done
erase the data banks
to gray throwback to repellent Commando
free houses
[Music]
huh
God they're so great Fireball
boys let's get out of here
all the clones have is each other that's
all they ever really needed
it's a republic of friendship
did they succeed they didn't erase the
data
Shake
oh man what a good loyal Soldier good on
him they always have that
make it fast the reinforcements are here
we got trouble
I love that Imperial March
[Music]
oh man oh man oh man genius
incredible it's interesting that they
were taking the Clone somewhere I wonder
if they need their clone genetics
remember they had that like super clone
assassin guy yeah I wonder if they're
doing some yeah some something yeah so
no definitely it's all tied in
I hate feeling bad for Crosshair
that's the last kind of prisoner you
want to nudge the doctor is on his way
be smart and cooperate well he will
resort to methods you will not enjoy
this guy scares me a little bit tell me
how to find clone Force 99
they'll never turn her over
they don't have a choice she is a clone
in their property help me locate your
former Squad and you will have your
freedom the way she looked at that
I don't know where they are
he really doesn't know where they are no
how would he but you know how they think
how they operate
have something useful to share
wrong Sinister
let's see if we can jog your memory oh
mind flare begin
oh even better nice That's a classic
it's gonna get laid one of our transport
ships was attacked departing balmora
prisoners aboard
inform me when he's ready to talk
I still feel like her and Django just
had a baby and that baby
sure would explain the accent I guess
that's not genetic
Coruscant
I recovered a portion of the data logs
heavily encrypted but I know someone who
can crack it I'll take care of things
here and see what else I can find out
I love you Echo I thought that was
really the dialogue
that's pretty good
he can't talk if he's dead
something going on here
you may secure strengths
nicely done don't make this worse
Crosshair There Is No Escape lower the
Blaster oh
oh he's done okay
that's surprisingly Humane of him she's
attractive
[Music]
oh my God
but in this condition he still still
landed still eventually landed he just
had to Sundance get it you know
now you are so badass Crosser I love
this breaking out of the medical
facility
someone's reached his Tipping Point
Tipping Point Tipping Point what if
there's like a distress code or
something it can send out to the bad
batch
yes
this would put them all in the same
place at the same time
you can make one phone call
no get out of there somehow
I feel like I could beat sleeping gas
[Music]
willpower
it's about find out next week
it's my own special Formula One I built
in immunity to
oh man
return to Pabu welcome to Disneyland I
love it
well we rebuilt all of Papu it only took
one episode
become an integral part of this
community
you all have
any chance you've reconsidered staying
permanently he's in love with him
more flying lessons uh-huh
text got his hands full
you guys look so concerned though when
you saw the ship
no way that is awesome
she has to learn sometime
yikes you playing it you're gonna cause
another sea search
[Laughter]
the Collision alums haven't gone off
once because it shorted out during your
last lesson
execute a sharp swing back to port with
zero Thruster pull the tick turn nice
now that is not what it is called but
I'd rather like it Oh Come to myself
[Music]
the attack turn
I love it how was that
much better
[Music]
they love waving in this island
doing a whole lot of it honestly you've
been keeping
up as promised God
Landing Zone I do not think that is a
sound
oh my God
I love this
put your money on shoot down Echo ship
yeah
wave
oh God it was
so scary looking I don't oh you look
like them but no weird this place is
remote
that has its advantages
preciousness people yeah wow there's
they're all like NPCs that's exactly
there this is what's left of the files
are recovered from an imperial shuttle
it was transporting clone prisoners and
we need to know where and why on
crosshair's name is going to be on it oh
they're gonna save Crosshair the attack
on the prisoner transport ship is
unfortunate but inconsequential governor
simply decommissioning problematic
clones will not eliminate the threat if
you send them to me I can deal with them
in other ways this guy's a pervert full
briefing on your plan
Summit
that sounds like a fun thing to be at I
really like him he's one of my favorite
scary Star Wars music explanation it's
not a compelling villain and not just
the echo you've seen the power you're up
against
you can't defeat them
it's not about that it's about fighting
for our brothers it's our family I
understand why you're doing this but
when will it be enough
Hunter I decrypted the data you need to
get back to the ship oh yep not ominous
or nothing previous transfer records
recovered from the ship's logs list
other clone prisoners detained by the
advanced science Division and Crosshair
is one of them
after discovering his clone number on
the transfer register I checked our old
Cub plan 88. the Seeker we are being
targeted I believe he is warning us
you know or it's a trap it's a trap like
he said for us before how do we find out
we go into the Trap
I can't pay extra for that
sir
ens now you'd like to reconsider my
office
why suffer more all I need is the young
clone
she means nothing to you they do keep
ominously cutting or they might be
increases injection level this time
I just see how long until you break
she does look like Omega yeah right
this poor guy
crosshair's done nothing wrong
all right well [__] let's talk about it
let's start off first by talking for 30
minutes about the Pabu episode and then
maybe like five minutes on the Tipping
Point episode because let's face it the
real meat and substance
was the Pabu episode you know I feel
like if you're a fan of Pabu natural
disasters yeah oh I love natural
disaster big fan I do too I have a
collection any natural disaster anytime
I see the sea
dissipate
and then turn into a giant wave yeah I
am fulfilled on a physical
yeah level it's like the song Sail by
Awolnation
that was actually what I was gonna say
yeah
we're on the same page no it uh I I
thought it was
the first episode was fun
um I appreciate that we got a taste of
the what that there are
other possibilities out there
um yeah and we'll end right away and I
and I but I feel like it was it was nice
for I mean each of them kind of found
a new sense of purpose and yeah they
didn't
this idea of
I mean we've seen it with other clones
you know there was the the Clone who
fathered children and and was living a
relatively happy life when he ran into
wrecks during Clone Wars
um and uh and I think it's nice because
I think we we needed to see that before
they really have to make this Choice
you're trying other people the guy in
the first season of the show bad batch
right that's correct yeah he helped them
uh he helped them get their their
passports or whatever the heck it was
um but no I I really
um
as as slow as episodes like that are
um it was nice I think it that's
probably our last reprieve uh for the
season before it gets crazy doubted I
think the final episode will just be
very much Papu focused yeah or SID
focused
we're setting up season three yes it is
the big well it kind of makes me wonder
God I hope Sid doesn't have a redeeming
moment at the end of the season I really
hope that we just write Sid off and
pretend like it didn't happen I know
exactly what's mark my words I have a
solid prediction let's hear it that's
your non-sarcastic prediction I'm ready
for it Greg okay Luke Skywalker shows
that way I got it on sarcastic
prediction here is that it's like he's
he's like
not even three years ago but he'll show
up still
slicing down
power converters yeah uh that they're
gonna be in a bind
the Clones they're gonna need to escape
after they go to this facility
and guess who's going to help out
sit Sid's gonna help get them out of a
tough bind
obviously probably with the help of fee
yeah who is yeah yeah watch and if I'm
wrong
I will go into the YouTube editor and
delete this out of the video
you know
I really hope that's not the case
um we'll see I I feel like there's so
many just wait Michael yeah I I
definitely
I am increasingly convinced that uh
Omega is going to end up captured at the
end of the season and that Crosshair
will be returned to the group and that
that will be the Crux of a potential
third season yeah and uh
I think wrecker will end up losing his
mind constantly thinking he's talking
with Omega but it's Crosser
sad he keeps wanting to like cuddle with
crosshairs
I'm not yeah so
all jokes aside I do think it's really
interesting did not agree to that what
their
throws off your game that's okay I'm I'm
focused at it I'm on it I have sincere
passion about this uh I think it's
interesting that they're taking these
clones to clearly rewire them
um when we saw that clone assassin a
couple episodes back
um it all makes a little bit more sense
um and uh yeah I'm I'm curious I mean
it's been really I can't imagine anyone
anyone watching this isn't also watching
the Mandalorian
um and it is kind of fun to see if I
want to meet that fast yeah I want to be
that one committed a bad man I'm not
really into the bad batch but or I'm not
really into the mandal form but I love
it yeah give up Amanda Lauren but stick
it in with that man yeah just grogu
didn't do nothing
um but uh I I do love I I don't think
it's a coincidence that the end of bad
batch ties in with you know a premiere
of a new Mandalorian episode
um and I hope that I think it will be I
hope there is some connective tissue
there I mean obviously filoni being all
over the last few episodes as indicative
of that I think you're getting your
hopes extremely high for something
that's not gonna pan out all I'm saying
is I feel like in the final episode we
will see Mall dueling Hondo and and they
will decapitate Sid honestly if they
killed offset at the end of this season
and Omega was captured and that was the
setup of the third season I would be
super super stoked for the next season
yes how they kill off Sid
sacrifice she self-sacrifices I hope
it's selfish I hope she
I hope she she chokes
on one of the popcorn things you know
that they have here and why not yeah uh
no but I I like the latter episode uh
obviously um I mean I don't get me wrong
I thought the first episode of Pabu was
like Pleasant I was even fine without
there being a conflict but they needed a
reason to keep them around other than
yeah sure we'll we'll live in your
Utopia here and and I I like uh I like
the idea of them having that choice and
maybe the show will end with them
residing in Pabu which would be cool but
the the second episode uh was the
episode 14 was definitely a lot more
interesting I do like this villain I was
very much compelled by him the first
time he showed up I thought like maybe
he's a famous actor but I've never heard
of the actor who voices him and the the
Builder that they do have to it would
cross her uh coming back it's just in
Crosshair while you sparingly in this
season has easily been the most
compelling to me of the main characters
in Tech
Tech I was I would say is the second
pick for that I mean I think Tech
exploring romances like has been a
well-deserved uh we've seen text slowly
figure out how to be a human and I feel
like that's the last big step like and
if Greg can do it surely Tech can too so
love find love oh yes I'm still learning
what humor is well my programming hasn't
quite caught up there yet that's okay uh
the data in me is rendering
yeah I'm I'm super curious
so one of the hard Parts but also I
think one of the my favorite Parts about
the show is that to an extent we kind of
know how it ends in in that I never
really have heard about a clone
rebellion in any kind of like major
sincere way and
you've heard about it in ways but not in
a sincere way yeah no no
those guys are such jerks when they talk
now uh but I I wonder if in their
failure
um
maybe there is a success that does play
into something future down the line
um all we know is that by the time of
rebels there is at least
three survivors of the Clone Rebellion
I think
you don't hear concern yourself of
knowing how things end that's all Star
Wars now
everything we watched from Star Wars we
know how it's all going to end but do we
do we as in the character from Scream no
as in like oh the question no do we no
do we as in the middle duck in Huey
Dewey and Louie
yes no but but
I feel like I like reviewing this show
more than reviewing Mandalorian
me too I know because I feel
there's less stakes in when we talk the
stakes are so high in this
and the reason why Greg is because this
is
Star Wars I think has actually done a
pretty extraordinary job at
uh without entirely retconning
filling in gaps and making things like
for instance in Andor seeing a piece of
of the Death Star be created like
we see all these little pieces connect
that tell a larger story that connects
to Rogue one I mean even figuring out
like all the actions that went into
blowing up the Death Star and submitting
those plans it means the whole Crux
I can't help but imagine that bad batch
will have a similar conclusion at least
with the Clone rebellion and while we
know how it ends
I still love that
yeah I like it too
sincere to disagree
well thank you guys for watching our
review uh I hope that you have and you
don't want to talk for 20 more minutes
Greg has a Mandalorian to edit so uh no
but uh what did you all think I'm super
curious where do you think this clone
rebellion's going they're gonna lose
or are they or maybe wait is there a
book on I Don't Know Jack about the
Clone Rebellion is there a book about
the Clone Rebellion no I mean it's it's
subtly alluded to in in a lot of
different places that there were clones
Who Rose up against but also like maybe
they all know maybe like but actually
like maybe I mean
um we know that uh
the only clones that we've seen post
Empire in uh in any kind of form after
like bad batch is Boba Fett
no well yeah it's technically clone but
I'm talking about like clone troopers is
an Obi-Wan Kenobi we see the homeless
guy
um and then in uh Star Wars Rebels uh we
see Gregor uh Rex and um wolf and one
other guy
Luke Skywalker okay that's it uh but
other than that no we really don't know
the the fate of of the Clones
um and it makes you wonder I mean that
would be a good movie the fate of the
Clones well I
they live short lives
um
well Rex is at Endor
is he yeah he is in fact if you watch
this is true this is true for those of
you that don't know this if you watch
Return of the Jedi there's an old dude
with a beard and he looks just like Rex
and no this is no hear me out George
Lucas no of course he didn't plan this
but Dave filoni says that's right well
when they designed what older version of
Rex looked like for Star Wars Rebels
they built the model around it and then
in the epilogue for Rebels uh sandula
mentions that Rex fought in the Battle
of Endor which means Rex could have been
at Anakin's funeral
same with Ahsoka
which is kind of an interesting uh I'd
love to like go back and do another
special edition of Return of the Jedi
and and just pan out a little bit after
the the fourth ghost and there's just
this is just like slightly pan left
next to that tree yeah
the Director of Photography just didn't
get it free
I mean honestly that would be a really
smart way to start the Ahsoka show yeah
like like oh why is this character
important zupo that's why so well I mean
how but I'm saying like those guys lived
long they're old as [__] in the in that
show well they age it twice the rate of
a normal person yeah but did they
yeah all of them did everyone but Boba
who ages at that's why Boba is the age
that he's at uh in uh Mandalorian but
Rex did age twice as fast did he really
he did I thought he aged normally
considering the timeline of where he's
at at the final episode of rebels at the
final episode of rebels we're talking
about uh I mean it's the Battle of
sometimes the timeline gets a little
confusing but it's been like what 20 30
years since uh oh you're right he does
look 97 years old yeah well granted I
mean Rex was around
from the original Battle of Geonosis
um fact check me on that I'm pretty sure
as well yeah I mean and you see some of
those clones involved there at the end
of rebels so I I'd assume that they do
find some way to find some Haven yeah
hopefully I mean they were just
responsible for that they help out with
that I just I can't help but imagine
that they did something successfully
critical that changed the course of
history and the Empire might have like
written it out of the textbooks but I'm
sure we'll get to see it I think that's
what's been happening for years with
Star Wars
is Empire forgot to jot down a lot and
we've been seeing a lot of it play out
over the years well you know so long as
uh Disney plus continues to Hemorrhage
money and as long as those ratings keep
skyrocketing like they have skywalkering
skywalkering yeah they have been through
the roof I was trying to keep this at it
short and you just kept it going but I
like talking to you I really want to
know after this I have to edit before
and a procrastinating photography so
reject Nation question for you uh what
do you think happens to the clones uh
after the Clone Rebellion uh do they
succeed clearly not but what happens
alternatively do they end up using
manscape yeah do they use manscape uh
honestly if you watch Rebels I would
argue that wolf definitively has the
beard trimmer because that's like yeah
if you go to
um Return of the Jedi you can see
there's a person there who is manscaping
himself so manscape is is Canon to the
Star Wars yeah we should answer the
patron of the day shut up wow patron of
the day
pick a name on there uh Flav Flav Doran
I don't think you watched this show we
usually Reserve you for Marvel content
but you have been randomly selected by
The Imperials
to get a shout out here today hey by Sir
Michael the Tesla hey there
flev Dorian you have the coolest first
off if you don't watch bad batch you
should because there's no way there's
not a character that also has your name
in this show I know it's a great name
it's a super super amazing name super
amazing name yeah
[Music]
uh actually flap is one of our most
engaged patrons he's constantly leaving
very enthusiastic strong feedback and
comments always saying like ah John I
love you let me tell you why and he's
constantly being like Oh koi dude you're
the best your knowledge then you tends
to leave comments like Greg here's what
I think you need to improve about how
you come across on camera yeah
um sometimes well I think I've read some
of his comments actually I know yeah
dude I totally agree you're like right
on the money I tried telling Greg all
the time I am constantly trying to find
validation from flev yeah it's a
constant search and flev knows that the
only reason that I'm getting better is
because I keep casting my fish hook into
the sea of Life hoping touch us reel him
out of there yeah and I'm just not doing
who needs Dory when you've got Doran
not your best not my best not your best
okay I'll just keep swimming all right
well fluffdorn thank you for being a
loyal reject
um I say this from the bottom of my
heart
um Greg needs your validation please
help we need you you are our only name
of my autobiography the search for
validation
face
resembling conflict
all right okay well Flav we're done yeah
and uh F is for the feelings no you only
go for first time I did you know I don't
know
who knew I didn't know that's that is
the second time I've done it
the F in your name
stands for the Friendship we'll never
have because Greg will let me do the
letter no that's all all right yeah
unless you make another account you have
a dragon this video out
[Laughter]
that's a wrap
foreign